[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les directives et 10h37
mais les crêtes pensez vous c'est fait
par des professions
et que j'adore voilà trouvé en train de
jouer à des chiffres des dérapages et là
dans la fois que je suis noir c'était
sûr j'aimerais bien qu'elle m'aime pas
demoiselle ben ali
rioux pour lesquels boîtes à 5 à 5 alors
c'est un petit 42 jean minot tu peux me
sortir l'escarpin onu buts en 42 et demi
l'a9 l'a71 donne aussi de porter la
place on ne vais pas te dire moi je
réponde à gaz on entend des détonations
compaq ce n'est pas un petit peu too
much faisant du mbba et c'est vrai que
depuis je me sens beaucoup mieux dans
mon corps oui quand même
dis toi ça fait chaud de ouf dans danse
avec les stars n'ont sam à 18 ans
aujourd'hui exceptionnellement outre
alors ça c'est de la petite camargue est
à faire un carton ce traité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez
qui paie
je peux juste me permettre sophie sur
ton zouk
j'ai vu tu fais 5 6 7 et 8 j aurais bien
que tu fasses
initiative dans le dos
[Rires]
j'ai ainsi c'est un saltimbanque l'âge
est un démon j'ai un démon thaïlandais
j'ai qu'un médium l'âge et la vie est
belle ici ouais j'ai une brique à 9 en
dessous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]